mais il ya quand même une vérité c'est
la raison pour laquelle je m'adresse à
edouard philippe
c'est que votre majorité a été ces
derniers mois ces dernières semaines
extraordinairement généreuse généreuse
de son mépris à l'égard de tous ceux et
de toutes celles qui ne pensent pas
comme elle
ce fut d'abord si vous me permettait de
le rappeler le hashtag balance son maire
ensuite nous avons nous avons
l'automobiliste qui nécessairement fume
des clopes roulant diesel pourquoi pas
des gitane maïs et pourquoi pas du pij
au mazout nous avons ensuite cette
situation absolument invraisemblable des
gilets jaunes qui ont le mérite de tirer
un signal d'alarmé
certes ils le font à leur façon qui
n'est pas la nôtre
mais c'est sans doute un degré profonde
exaspération méritait-il d'être
soupçonné d'être manipulés par l'ultra
droite et mérite est il plus grave
encore de que l'on puisse parler de
peste brune c'est méprisant pour des
français qui jusqu'à présent ne font que
manifester plus tranquillement je dirais
que plus grave que le mépris
il y à la pédagogie qui est en fait
votre condescendance à l'encontre des
français qui ne pensent pas comme vous
il se trouve que l'on peut partager des
opinions différentes
si les français n'adhèrent pas à la loi
de transition c'est sans doute qu'elle
est imparfaite et ma question est très
simple
premièrement allez-vous la changer
deuxièmement comptez-vous sur le
parlement pour le faire et non pas sur
les comités les plus respectables mais
qui ne sont pas au coeur de la
responsabilité
et j'ajoute enfin y aura-t-il un
moratoire pendant que les travaux
parlementaires prépare un nouvel
équilibre dont le pays a besoin
pour vous répondre la parole à monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur deux parties dans
votre question une première qui relève
de la remarque ou en vous écoutant
j'entends le la dénonciation de ce qui
serait du mépris de la condescendance
vous l'avez dit vous-même monsieur le
sénateur on a parfaitement le droit de
ne pas être d'accord ça nous arrive on a
d'ailleurs le droit aussi parfois d'être
d'accord ça nous arrive ça nous arrive
le débat politique est vif et il est vif
dans tous les sens je pense que vous
êtes comme moi attachée à la nuance est
à la mesure
il ne vous aura pas échappé monsieur le
sénateur reconnaissons le que sur tous
les bancs des deux assemblées et parfois
lorsqu'on est membre du gouvernement on
subit des critiques qui sont
parfaitement fondées c'est la démocratie
vous demandez mais en aucune façon qui
sont parfois dures elles sont allées
parfois peut-être un peu excessive
elles sont même parfois blessantes
chacun des ministres chacun des
ministres peut citer des exemples et
chacun des parlementaires dans sa vie
politique peut citer des exemples
d'attaqués parfois injuste et parfois
blessantes dont il a pu faire l'objet
j'essaye pour ma part et vous le savez
parfaitement monsieur le sénateur
j'essaie pour ma part monsieur le
sénateur de rester toujours dans
l'expression mesurée et nuancée toujours
et je ne doute pas qu'un jour on me le
reprochera en faisant justement état
d'une forme de condescendance
il n'en est rien j'essaie simplement
d'utiliser les moules les plus adaptées
est ce que je crois les plus justes pour
décrire une réalité qui est toujours
complexe et monsieur le sénateur elle
est toujours complexe cette réalité est
ce qu'on peut se dire entre nous que
reconnaître la bonne foi d'un certain
nombre pardon reconnaître la bonne foi
de ceux qui ont
mis un gilet jaune pour manifester est
possible dire qu'ils expriment une
colère une angoisse un désaccord qui est
parfaitement légitime est possible le
dire et l'assumé et en même temps dire
qu'à l'occasion à l'occasion un certain
nombre d'entre eux pas tous et qu'on
peut faire la différence ont eu un
comportement qui relève à l'évidence de
quelque chose qui n'est pas l'expression
simplement de la colère ou de leurs
angoisses mais qui est bien
le franchissement d'une limite de
l'intimidation c'est arrivé à des
parlementaires de l'intimidation
physique de la menace physique c'est
arrivé à des collègues parlementaires ou
parfois à des destructions de biens
publics ou à des violences y compris à
l'égard des forces publiques le dire
monsieur le sénateur ce n'est pas faire
preuve de mépris ça n'est pas faire
preuve de condescendance c'est
simplement essayé de décrire une réalité
qui effectivement est complexe avec des
mots que je crois juste vous
m'interrogez et c'est la deuxième partie
de votre question sur la perspective qui
a été donnée par le président de la
république sur le cap en matière de
transition écologique et notamment de
trajectoire carbone le président de la
république a eu l'occasion de dire que
ce cap avait été fixé avait été présenté
aux français et qu'il n'en changerai pas
c'est un élément que je porte au débat
plus exactement qu'il apportait ce matin
au débat et que j'assume
pour ma part et devant l'assemblée
nationale comme devant le sénat
parfaitement
il a indiqué toute une série de
propositions tendant à faire en sorte
que les mesures d'accompagnement que
nous envisageons soit parfaitement
adaptée aux besoins des français et pour
travailler à ces mesures
d'accompagnement il lui a paru utile et
je pense qu'il a raison c'est mon avis
monsieur le sénateur il lui a paru utile
de procéder à une consultation pam pas
pardon monsieur le sénateur pas d'un
comité théodule de ce qu'on appelle
parfois et 200 dos ton de reproche
parfois de me connaître l'importance
qu'on désigne sous le nom de corps
intermédiaires
nous allons discuter de l'organisation
du débat et de ces mesures
oui monsieur le sénateur avec les
syndicats nous allons le faire
oui avec les associations de
consommateurs nous allons faire avec les
élus locaux qui eux aussi ont des
responsabilités en la matière nous mais
bien sûr nous allons le faire avec les
élus territoriaux qui était d'ailleurs
présent ce matin à la conférence au co
au conseil national de la transition
écologique
nous allons le faire avec les ong nous
allons le faire avec les acteurs du
débat public et une fois que une fois
que le mûrissement de ces mesures aura
était évidemment la discussion aura lieu
au parlement parce qu'elle ne peut pas
avoir lieu ailleurs
parce que nous disons monsieur le
sénateur depuis le début que les gilet
jaune exprimer une colère que nous
pouvons entendre que nous devons
entendre mais que à la fin dans notre
démocratie et dans notre république
c'est le parlement qui fait la loi
et voyez-vous monsieur et voyez vous
monsieur le sénateur dire cela c'est
exactement l'inversé du mépris c'est
exactement l'inversé de la
condescendance c'est consulter les corps
intermédiaires
ces essais nous et le débat avec les
français et c'est ensuite en tirer les
conséquences
devant le parlement car c'est devant lé
parlement que les décisions se tiennent
et quand je dis cela monsieur le
sénateur je n'ai pas le sentiment ni
d'affaires preuve de mépris ni faits ni
de faire preuve de condescendance
j'entends des interjections j'entends
des eaux je dis les choses telles que je
les envisage et j'essaie de répondre
complètement à votre question et je vous
en remercie
la parole